from the daily mail billionaires at war
elon musk deepens feud with bill gates
by touting article claiming the
microsoft mogul poured millions into
dark money fund targeting him
that is dastardly but before we show
anything i want to show you this
elon musk posting the pregnant man emoji
next to a photo of bill gates
so here's the funny thing he posted this
april 22nd and it shows you know bill
gates it's the haircut's the same
you know there's not wearing glasses but
he's got a big belly and a blue shirt
and uh you just need to understand that
elon posted this
uh bill gates had already been funding
these groups now here's the crazy thing
apparently bill gates reached out to
elon musk about donating or some kind of
philanthropy but was was running a 500 i
think it was 500 million right 500
million short against tesla and elon's
like i'm doing the most for climate
change and you're trying to short my
position i don't trust you so they've
kind of been going at it the one thing i
want to reiterate for this as we start
this segment is that elon is a guy who
said
we need more people you know if you you
need more people to sustain this the
civilization and this planet to colonize
other planets and all of that stuff and
people should have free speech should
have you know the right to use his
platforms and speak and and all that
stuff bill gates is the opposite he says
we need less people there's too many
and people shouldn't have that free
speech it's really interesting we have
these two billionaire factions going at
each other
so uh in this story
the report came out that bill gates
poured millions of dollars into dark
money fund attacking elon musk he
responded with psy
that's it but it does
it does say a lot as soon as elon
acknowledged breitbart what ends up
happening is breitbart began begins
trending on twitter
every every blue check journalist starts
claiming oh breitbart is fake news you
don't trust it and now they're trying to
claim you know once again like oh elon
musk he's far right or whatever i think
this just goes to show that there are
efforts to silence us from very powerful
interests
whether
you whether you like breitbart or not
bill gates absolutely is funding ngos
many of these many of these big
corporations we see we just saw state
farm i think it was a state farm they
had this thing where they were sending
you know lgbtq stuff for kids all of
this stuff is happening behind the
scenes all of these groups are you know
opposed to free speech
so what happens next
uh what do you guys think i think that
we double down on the u.s constitution
but i'd like to hear you yeah i mean to
me bill gates embodies kind of the tech
elitism that i fled when i left silicon
valley um
it very much is this very pompous
attitude that you know
if people are allowed like if we allow
these people to think for themselves
like they're gonna give us bad results
like and it is just like they're so
stupid we have to take care of them like
it's very much like there are there are
pets almost like i feel i don't feel
like bill gates is evil
but he doesn't trust
the everyday
person to kind of make their own
decisions read information read alex
jones or watch alex jones right watch
all these things and come to their own
conclusions
um whereas elon musk does seem to be
you know to some degree you know
fighting kind of for the
the more common man fighting for a free
speech you know yes every like he's not
saying like only elite should have
children he's saying we should all have
more children things like that well he
actually had a tweet earlier he said i
think this is today right he said most
rich people he knows most people you
know says like have like one or two kids
yes or no it's like one or none right
yeah and then he's got eight yeah true
he has eight kids yeah there's a lot of
kids go dad
that's a lot of kids yeah i mean i mean
that's that is rampant in silicon valley
this this belief
and i think it was big in the 70s too
just like
there's too many kids like
a lot of them think that there should be
licenses to have kids um they don't even
have kids
yeah they don't have kids themselves
you're right i mean i i gotta say
haven't you uh ever encountered someone
that was just so stupid you were like
you know what bill gates is right
yeah absolutely but but it's it's you
know
they're
you got to you got to believe in free i
mean for me i believe in freedom first
so yeah like
maybe you see that person and think that
but then who's going to work at the
licensing office right maybe that guy so
yeah right
exactly when i think about how they
founded the us the us government it was
kind of like an elitist they had an
elite like they were like we can't trust
the common man to govern themselves so
we're going to create a congress to do
it for them just in case no that is the
common man well it's a representative of
the common man yeah i think the most
intelligent among them to i mean what
were they going to do they weren't going
to do direct democracy because that
doesn't work mobs are dangerous but but
the you know before the united states it
was a king who ruled by decree and it
was just like do as you're told pay your
taxes and they were like we just want
representation they're like no i think
with social media when you get like what
they call fake news or like
misinformation disinformation it's the
mob mentality that's dangerous if a
piece of bad information goes out and
then everyone shares it or if 50 million
people share it it's kind of like
democracy in action and i get i see the
danger in it yeah no bad things can
happen i mean there was a problem where
some indian
village or we've been told there was an
indian village that started like
murdering tourists because there was
some like superstition about
torah that spread on whatsapp like but
at the end of the day
you know
yeah it's a it's a double-edged sword
i'm gonna go for i'm gonna be on the
side of freedom they they they have this
uh utopian view of everything saying
like there's a problem happening we can
solve it you can't solve it
you you can't and we're we're witnessing
this with
all of the big tech stuff they they try
banning memes and then what happens they
end up banning the you know random
people on accident and banning a bunch
of regular people the famous moment was
when the editor-in-chief of the daily
caller got banned for referencing
learn to code because they created an
automated system saying okay anybody
saying learn to code you got to ban them
why
they're a bunch of white like you know
what it really feels like they're a
bunch of they're like the class
president you know they're snooty and
elitist and they're angry that
everyone's laughing and having fun and
they're like stop having fun is not
allowed and so they just like tell the
algorithm to ban anybody says learn to
code that's a really bad idea here's a
really great example remember when the
ceo of reddit went to the donald and
manually changed the comments from
donald users because he was mad at them
talk about a whiny pathetic
loser
someone said mean words so he went into
the reddit database and changed what
they said
yeah that guy's just so sad what a loser
and he's got how much money see this is
the problem this is why i agree we can't
we can't be like we need licensing and
we need to restrict free speech because
then you get losers like that in charge
of the system which you have now and
they flex their muscles thinking i
should be in charge and then the do
petty garbage like that
how sad
my biggest takeaway from the from the
breitbart piece as well is that so many
of those arguments are made in bad faith
which i think is what you're getting at
you know the same people who are now
saying we don't want this this uh this
purchase you know they have ties to bill
gates or they have ties to other
industry people um the same people who
before this saga were saying you know
actually there is no censorship
everything is just it's just moderation
and all that when elon says he's maybe
going to buy this
suddenly there is censorship and not
only is it real it's actually essential
that it continue for our democracy to
continue to function and in all cases
these arguments are you know there were
bad faith arguments before and and
they're being revised i understand local
censorship like uh in your house it's
your rules and if the kids speak up out
of turn you know it's your house they
follow your law that's you're censoring
your but top-down censorship doesn't
work doesn't seem to work not i mean not
really not really you well
sedition laws and stuff parents and kids
and small you know private homes is one
thing it's like it's my house if
somebody comes over and they act up i'm
gonna be like bro you can leave it's my
house now that's the argument we we see
from a lot of democrats like it's a
private company and i'm just like yeah
who controls the common space where
adults are all trying to discuss with
each other there is no super parent
there's no like
you know after you're 100 years old 100
years old you elevate to a higher
authority of adult no no we're all
adults we all have thoughts and opinions
we all have rights and we're going to
argue those things
they think they shouldn't have to argue
at all they think they should just be
able to stamp you out and a good example
is what's happening with this lawsuit
democrats are trying to disqualify
republicans instead of saying i'm going
to stand in front of the common people
and tell them my thoughts and my plans
i'm going to go to the judge and say he
shouldn't be allowed to run for office
come on judge ban him because they can't
win they don't want to actually play by
the rules they're whiny pathetic losers
what have you guys found is the most
resilient
i guess resistance towards this stuff at
this point
in what fashion well like uh the best
tech you could build to to circumvent
censorship or like censorship that's
gone too far
well i mean you kind of talking about
like one of the biggest hurdles that we
have to overcome i mean i would say like
it's gotten way worse with the app
stores with with
iphone
totally locking down their computer it
used to be that you could program
whatever you wanted and
your friends could install it and now
apple approves what you can do
and they'll even like like take you off
of the store if your buttons and you
know if steve jobs is corpse doesn't
like where your button is
um you'll you can get removed from the
store
um for real they'll remove stuff for
design yes yes really
what's an example of that well
um
they have very strict guidelines for for
their designs so
um
so my company that i helped start in
2014 we got removed because it was um
it wasn't quite for design it was
because and it wasn't really removed it
was just we couldn't upgrade it and it
was because
um
they weren't happy that we were allowing
people we were we were we we kind of
looked like we had a list of games they
were like oh you have a list of games in
your app that's that's kind of our job
we have the list of games on our thing
so like
we we might be competing too much with
apple
and then they they said we couldn't
upgrade until we made it feel
like it was less of a
list of games and more like a chat app
they said it's okay if you have a chat
app it's not okay if you have a list of
games yeah roblox is on the apple app
store and it is the that's exact thing
it's a list of games they call them
experiences right so they've they've
they it's
you probably deal this with youtube all
the time they like their guidelines are
always shifting right so they kind of
have this gray area where they can
operate in and they can
enforce things
in a irregular fashion
and they
absolutely
have like people at facebook
who you know they facebook gets to do
what they want way more than like a
smaller developer gets to do what they
want
and like if you're an open source
developer trying to create like you know
something federated like matrix or
something it's even harder when you're
looking at f droid whenever i think
about like open source app stores i
think of f droid is that good or is it
dangerous or what's the deal i mean they
would say it's dangerous i think it's
great like i want more people using you
know the the open source the um
they're they're called the uh they're
basically operating systems based on the
android open source project
which you know
people have
removed the google control from so yeah
you can install graphene os or lineage
os and install f droid and kind of get
whatever apps you want but this is you
know for the average person they have no
idea what you just said to be honest you
know what's f droid what is yeah and
that's kind of i agree that's that's one
of the things that we really want to
focus on with futo too is educating
people about their options and also
making them better i mean we have to
admit that
the oligopoly is doing a great job at
building these things like
very easy the product is really good
that's the the first problem with with
the tech oligopoly please
yes
the app store i think is one thing
that's often overlooked in the
discussion about free speech because
that's probably the most important
because even if you like
we all saw gab get pulled from the app
store and banned and then they have to
find alternative means means to get in
getting back on the app store one of the
funniest things i think they did was
they created a clone of the uh the
fetiverse app
which is it's just a
it's there's no website it's just a
shell
then you plug in where you want to go
and oh it can boot up you know gabs you
know servers
that got banned too and they were like
it's a clone i think it was a clone of
mastodon or something and so i was like
why was that i wasn't a clone of bad
medicine i think it was a clone of
fetiverse
so for those that aren't familiar with
what this means it's like a web browser
it's like they ban your website so you
launch your own web browser and then
they ban your web browser and it's just
that
that's how insane the control of these
two app stores really is
maybe maybe there's something there i
mean you know bill gates got hit for
antitrust for what putting internet
explorer on all these uh windows
machines is that what happened
yeah that was in the late 90s when um
netscape was uh dominating the browser
market and
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in monday through friday at 8 pm
and if you want more special access
content head over to timcast.com and
become a member your membership helps
sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there
you